fasching es tut mir leid ich muss das
thema ändern
sie haben mich aufgerufen über lindners
tank rabatt ihr seien die beiden darüber
reden aber ich glaube war denke ich ist
er dazu alles gesagt nur ein einsatz wir
wollen als union über die steuer über 40
cent beim sprit nachlassen und da ist
das angebot an die ampel koalition
gesetzt kein kleinen
minimal london sondern wirkliche
entlastung aber das eine kommt mit dem
anderen zusammen nämlich dass wir in
deutschland diesen krieg spüren spüren
werden auch in den kommenden monaten und
da müssen wir alles daran legen in einer
welt die komplizierter geworden ist wenn
ich beispielsweise die taiwan
problematik mit china sehe die
lieferketten die globalen die
exportwirtschaft in deutschland und die
größte logistikbranche der welt nämlich
in deutschland logistik weltmeister lebt
davon dass wir offen sind dass wir auch
funktionierende lieferketten haben und
deswegen braucht es ein starkes
deutschland des bündnis drohe ist es in
der europäischen union eine starke
stimme hat aber das was wir jetzt bauen
in deutschland um den sozialen frieden
zu gewährleisten ist runter bei den
energiepreisen runter bei den
spritpreisen damit wir auch die
solidarität dafür haben und die stärke
dafür haben aus unserer wirtschaftlichen
kraft heraus die kommenden monate wo es
auch migrationsströme geben wird zu
meistern und da müssen wir jetzt darauf
achten dass wir diese balance halten
diese balance zum einen in der globalen
verantwortung in unserem wissen über
eine starke außenpolitik dazu kommen und
auch über eine bündnispolitik die schlau
ist um dann eines zu erreichen nämlich
dass putin endlich aufhört zu bomben-
und da ist meine these wir brauchen auch
die die auf russischer seite das geld
haben dazu den druck auf putin
zu erhöhen denn momentan ist nur auf
russischer seite putin und ich würde mir
wünschen dass wir bald über eine nach
putin zeit reden können und es geht nur
mit einem druck aus russland heraus das
ist es noch weit weg wir brauchen erst
den ersten schritt nehme ich den frieden
in nuuk rheine aber das muss unser aller
aufgabe sein wir werden sehen dass wir
mit diesem
putin krieg an dieser stelle schluss
machen müssen und alles darum tun müssen
das wieder die partnerschaft mit auch
russischen menschen ob das über die
wissenschaft ist ob dies über die
wirtschaft ist sich in langfristig
entwickelt weil mit putin wird vieles
zerstört werden was mir unglaublich
angst macht
sozialer sprengstoff herr mordhorst
naja also natürlich wird das sozialen
sprengstoff mit sich bringen wir sind zu
einer großen abhängigkeit von russischer
energie gekommen die wir jetzt verlassen
müssen und ich möchte da wirklich auch
mal respekt für meinen es wurde gleich
das bundesland als auch andere parteien
nämlich robert habeck aussprechen der
das sehr sehr klar gesagt hat wir müssen
energie politisch unabhängig werden das
wird teuer werden das wird auch die
menschen etwas abverlangen wir versuchen
da abzufedern zu dämpfen aber ich will
die leute auch nicht anlügen wir müssen
uns jetzt verändern wir müssen
entscheidungen was die energie was die
wirtschaft was die sicherheit angeht
strategischer begreifen längerfristiger
begreifen und deswegen glaube ich
stimmen wir im grundsatz über ein obwohl
ich jetzt nicht so ganz den punkt genau
verstanden habe aber ich glaube wir sind
uns einig wir müssen energie politisch
unabhängig werden und mehr
entscheidungen strategischer und
langfristiger betrachtet richtig dann
vorträge aber einer sehr haarweg nicht
nur nach innen agiert sondern jetzt so
wie es die amerikaner machen auch neue
partnerschaften gründet in der
versorgung mit beispielsweise erdöl und
kohle denn da müssen jetzt neue
partnerschaften gegründet werden und das
zweite sage ihnen voraus dass wir einen
reset brauchen einen kompletten reset
der europäischen landwirtschaftspolitik
weil wir werden nämlich über
versorgungssicherheit in rehden bei den
lebensmittel wenn wir uns darauf
verlassen haben wenn du keine weizen
anzubauen und auf europäischer ebene
lieber flächenstilllegungen machen oder
renaturierungs programm oder den zubau
auf fruchtbaren boden durch regenerative
energien verbauen dann werden wir hier
viele viele fragen noch einmal neu
diskutieren müssen in der europäischen
union die landwirtschaftspolitik ist
sehr europäisch geprägt weil ich glaube
dass das notwendig ist um genau das zu
erreichen was sie richtigerweise sagen
eine neue souveränitäts debatte in
deutschland und europa zu machen
souverän von allen anderen dingen wir
haben über bei der korona pandemie über
einen
text lappen geredet nehmen namens maske
dass man das aus china brauchen und
haben uns beklagt dass wir keine eigene
produktion sind haben das ist das ist
locker zu machen über was wir jetzt in
diesem russland krieg und den folgen
reden ist über lebensmittel über viele
viele
langfristige dinge
ja natürlich sage ich ihnen ganz bewusst
ich habe in den letzten jahren und
jahrzehnten erlebt dass wir uns immer
stärker auf andere verlassen und dass
wir vielleicht auch einen
transformationsprozess anstoßen den ich
sogar ganz unterstützen möchte was die
ökologie betrifft und die ökonomie
betrifft dass wir eine andere produktion
haben andere antriebstechnik allergien
innovation an erster stelle setzen
völlig okay aber trotzdem braucht es
einen reset in einer souveränitäts
debatte gerade wenn ich an die
landwirtschaftspolitik denke da haben
die bäuerinnen und bauern viel viel
mitgemacht mit der europäischen union
und da möchte ich eine andere strategie
aus den lehrern diese situation wissen
sie einsatz noch ein ich hab ich habe
einen senior landwirt der sich einen
lebenstraum erfüllt hat in der ukraine
als bayer als deutscher dort junge
menschen auszubilden in einer riesen
landwirtschaft die junge generation hat
den betrieb in meinem wahlkreis passe
übernommen und dieser lebenstraum der
ist jetzt zerstört weil er sagt ich habe
immer darauf gebaut dass wir in einer
friedlichen welt leben und dass wir
gemeinsam gesunde lebensmittel
produzieren und das müssen wir neu
diskutieren und ehrlich diskutieren
ich mag auch im ausland ich komme aus
europa und ich komme aus deutschland ich
glaube an ein vereintes europa und uns
mal nicht auch sagen dass eigentlich die
europäische union und so lange auf den
frieden gebracht hat also ich meine die
den zusammenhalt der länder ist auch der
grund warum wir so lange kein krieg
hatten oder das ist sicherlich so dass
nun kann man ganz klar unterstreichen
also europa ist ein friedensprojekt nach
innen hin gewesen jetzt ist die frage
kann es auch nach außen sein wir sehen
ja dass viel der sachen die gerade
passieren die jetzt nicht so mondän
aussehen trotzdem durch die europäische
union geleistet werden also
energiesicherheit organisieren wenn ich
in der nato und wir sind auch nicht
national sondern die organisiert wie
europäische hat deutschland
nachholbedarf wer das muss man auch ganz
klar sagen aber wenn wir jetzt über neue
partnerschaften reden dann ist die frage
sind das wirklich neue qualitativ oder
fallen wir in die alte falle neue
abhängigkeiten rein das heißt wir müssen
unsere neuen partner schon genau
angucken also wir sind denn wenn sie
kohle lieferanten haben wollen wer ist
denn dieses land das uns in zukunft die
kohle liefert neben den umweltfragen das
mal beiseite gestellt was mich
interessieren würde bei den vorschlägen
die sie machen und ich gehe im prinzip
mit bei ihnen beiden werd ich gehe mal
davon aus das muss ja nachher dann doch
irgendwie bezahlt werden wer zahlt das
nachher ist es die generation meiner
mutter es ist meine generation das ist
die generation meiner kinder also wie
machen wir das eigentlich wann kommt die
die zeche dafür nicht dass ich das
ablehnen würde sondern die frage ist für
mich bloß wer muss ich darauf eigentlich
vorbereiten dass er wie lange auf
bestimmten teil von wohlstand verzichten
muss hier würde ich gerne auch einmal
wollen die debatte reinholen der
hoffentlich ich habe jedes mal angst ist
die leitung aus irgendeinem grund nicht
mehr funktioniert nach kiew das ist
meine größte sorge man hier während der
sendungen war wenn du unsere reden hier
höher ist es gibt ja auch noch eine
sache die auch aktuell debattiert wird
und zwar ob die ukraine vielleicht zur
europäischen union gehören kann oder
sollte oder ob man einen plan aufstellen
würde die den bayern würde ich auch
gerne noch auf machen
ja also zur europäischen union und zur
möglichen mitgliedschaft habe ich eine
klare haltung das müsste so schnell wie
möglich passieren ich glaube zumindest
den beitrittsprozess zu beschleunigen da
sind wir der ukraine schuldig wenn wir
schon sonst wenig tun aus meiner sicht
was den widerstand gegen putin angeht da
ist gerade in diesen minuten etwas
interessantes passiert worauf ich gerne
eingehen möchte im russischen
staatsfernsehen gab es den protest einer
moderatorin war es glaube ich in der
journalisten die das studio dort mehr
oder weniger gestürmt hat und gegen den
krieg protestiert hat gegen den krieg
demonstriert hat
also es gibt diese mutigen menschen in
russland und wir werden jetzt
wahrscheinlich viele viele jahre im
gefängnis drohen aber wir sehen
zumindest zarte pflänzchen dieses
protests gegen wladimir putin und es
bleibt zu hoffen dass es weitere gibt
wir sehen das glaube ich wirklich und
bei allem was gerade schreckliches
passiert und was ein was an jeden tag
glaube ich auch schwer mitnimmt ist
glaube ich trotzdem wichtig eine lehre
daraus zu ziehen die nicht ist die
demokratie ist schwach oder unsere
westliche vorstellung von freiheit die
funktioniert nicht wir müssen maßgaben
ändern wir müssen selbst selbstständiger
werden strategischer denken aber putin
macht das doch aus angst weil er angst
vor seiner eigenen bevölkerung hat weil
die ukraine sich auf den weg nach westen
gemacht hat weil sie freiheit wollte
weil sie die nato in der verfassung
stehen hat als verfassungsziel und es
ist jedes jeden tag wieder schrecklich
was sie für einen preis dafür zahlen
muss muss aber trotzdem sollten wir
nicht an der idee der demokratie in
irgendeiner weise eine oder der idee der
demokratie eine schwäche attestieren
sondern gerade zeigen das ist stärke
dass sich auch von innen heraus etwas
ändern kann und das trotz eines solchen
massiven propaganda apparats wir in
russland ist trotzdem noch menschen sich
frei informieren sich sogar trotz
größter drohungen und konsequenzen
dagegen wenden das macht 1 macht einem
zumindest ein bisschen mut
wir sind nur hermeling die
antwort schuldig nämlich wer soll das
bezahlen ich glaube fakt ist
sind wir uns einig dass wir als deutsche
nur aus der deutschen sicht heraus immer
schon rohstoffe importieren mussten weil
wir selber zu wenig haben und deswegen
glaube ich dass eine große aufgabe
beispielsweise auf die wirtschaftliche
zusammenarbeit und entwicklungspolitik
zukommt denn es war die
wirtschaftspolitik das zu verstehen und
neue partnerschaften zu gründen
beispielsweise mit den wasserstoff
vorkommen in mali die sind nicht grün
also wenn man gleich springen will in
den grünen wasserstoff dann erkennt man
dass man zu neuen technologien und
regenerativen energien brücken braucht
und das war unser fehler der letzten
jahre zu sagen ich gehe von dem einen
extrem in das andere ich glaube wir
müssen brücken bauen in der dazwischen
in der zwischenzeit um neue
partnerschaften einzugehen also nicht
die ganz alten wieder aufzurufen sondern
es haben sich in der zwischenzeit neue
möglichkeiten geschaffen ich habe heute
ein gespräch mit dem botschafter gehabt
von einem land wo man nicht direkt daran
denkt dass man vielleicht dort auch
seltene erden oder auch rohstoffe
beziehen kann neue partnerschaften
gründen dort schon mal ein in welchem
land war in der botschaft der
botschafter aus der mongolei und
die mongolei ist groß mit wenig menschen
vielen tieren aber auch vor allem vielen
rohstoffen und es gab schon mal eine
partnerschaft eine bessere partnerschaft
zwischen deutschland und der mongolei um
genau neue technologien zu entwickeln
und das wäre dann der weg dorthin eine
so eine pipeline nord stream hat auch
geld gekostet also die hat auch
milliarden verschlungen warum gehen wir
nicht an anderen weg und suchen uns
partner mit neuen importmöglichkeiten
über rohstoffe und das zweite von ihnen
kann ich auch nur unterstreichen ich
glaube
ja es sind nicht nur zum streiten da
sondern wir haben ja viele
gemeinsamkeiten wenn es um krisen geht
es mache deutschland immer stark gemacht
das eine ist natürlich die die
fundamente der demokratie auf der
anderen seite muss ich in russland
feststellen dass es noch zu wenige gibt
die so mutig sind weil sie angst haben